hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new episode of the witching hour you
guys know me you know Haley that's not a
big deal here today we have director
Mike Doherty in studio right now
promoting Godzilla king of the monsters
I am so excited you're sitting here
right now I'm so excited because one I'm
obviously looking forward to Godzilla
but as I've told you many times before I
have an absolute obsession with
trick-or-treat that is never gonna go
away
and I'm never gonna stop reminding you
of it well that makes two of us
if only the fEARnet 24-hour marathon
still exists
rest in peace of various time No so to
jump into this here I was wondering just
because it seems like Warner Brothers is
making a big collection of some of my
favorite genre filmmakers and they're
putting them all in this specific
franchise have all of you guys ever kind
of sat down and POW out about just the
existence of this cinematic universe yes
we had a we've only had one one true
hangout night together I was like a
monster kelabra kaiju clip night but was
I was I was knee-deep in post-production
and Jordan the director of Skull Island
was gracious enough to host and so it
was him myself
Gareth and Adam who were now passing the
torch onto for Kong vs. Godzilla yeah it
was a good night that picture that
visual just kind of blows my mind it was
a really really good night what did you
get any Godzilla advice from either a
producer or any of the directors from
the previous films about yeah alright
what's the best Godzilla advice you got
I have to think about that it was just I
talked to Gareth frequently during
pre-production
and then Jordan was sort of my spirit
guide through post-production but
they're both such great guys and it
really is like probably one of the first
times in my life where I felt like I was
part of a fraternity of sorts
I was never a frat guy in college but
you know like what's a better fraternity
than a
monster 1 but you know they both they
both had to crawl through glass and walk
through the fire on their respective
films it was good to just know you
weren't alone
so do you have to pass the torch the
same way does that make you Adams spirit
guide now I I mean I'm I'm ready and
available we had a really great little
hangout in my kitchen just before he
left for Australia a couple months back
but I think he's more than capable
I definitely beyond in him yeah can you
tell us a little bit about specifically
casting Milly because I'm fascinated to
hear about that process is it simply a
matter of seeing what she's accomplished
on a show that has a fan base as rabbit
as stranger things and just offering her
the part or what can you tell us that
you see in her that we don't necessarily
get from stranger things uh well I mean
it was a really funny process casting
her because what happened was I was
doing previous animation during
pre-production and previous animation is
sort of like rough animated 3d
storyboards it helps it helps the
filmmaker sort of communicate to the
studio what you have in mind for a
certain sequence in our case we were
doing it to actually get the green light
so we did previous for three key action
set theses and one of them involved
Millie's character Madison Russell and
again it's before we even thought about
casting Millie but what happened was I
was such a fan of her on stranger things
as I pulled the previous artists you
know what just used million Bobby Brown
as reference for what she should look
like because I thought she has a very
soulful face you know she feels like an
old soul for me there was a glimmer of
Newt from aliens in her you know and so
they did the used her as reference and
uh and then as we were getting further
and further into the previs and we
started talking about casting I said
well why don't we just offer it to
Millie this before she had really blown
up she was starting to get notice but
but before she really became you know
this this goddess that she is and
legendary was completely behind the idea
so I went and had a meeting with her and
she had never really known that much
about Godzilla you know of course she
had heard the name
knew the movies existed but she was too
young to actually be a full-fledged fan
and so what I did is I explained to her
sort of about what the message of
Godzilla was because it turns out she's
just as much of an animal lover and a
nature lover as I am and we bonded over
that like she's got so many different
kinds of weird pets and turtles and
lizards and snakes and dogs and we had
that in common so she really clicked
into the into the message of Godzilla
and sort of how he protects the natural
world hearing that about her makes me
like her even more I know it's the worst
we were established in this room that we
are all genres yeah also I mean for the
most part everyone we've had sit at this
table is a pet lover today yeah and your
animal love in here if you don't like
the animals I don't know if I can trust
you like be friends with you period
Drago yeah smart smart choice love it I
to jump off the casting question want to
take that in a different direction which
is sort of casting the monsters so to
speak picking from the absolute arsenal
of monsters available in this Godzilla
tradition did you have sort of these
three as your main at the point that you
pitched it or was that did you decide on
them later in the process it was the
opposite shortly after the 2014 film
legendary approached oh ho about Rodin
Mothra in King Ghidorah so that was
already in motion they were baked in
four yeah well it was it was McKean
because legendary said they were
optional okay
you know they said listen we already got
the okay from Toho to use these guys and
would you be interested in of course I
mean yeah I mean they were the original
kaiju team-up yeah you know like they
were the Avengers of the Godzilla
franchise way back in the 60s so it was
a no brainer I mean I was happy they did
the work for me as this you know sort of
diehard fan of the franchise which I
know from reading here interviews you
very much are where when you know that
those are sort of the elements that you
have to play with to construct your act
scenes where does your mind go in
deciding just how you want to use those
incredible assets on screen it goes to
some really weird dark places no I mean
that's the thing is like just just
imagining a fun sequence with those
characters kind of writes itself in the
weirdest way because I grew up watching
those old movies but it was about
constructing sequences that truly
reflected them as characters because
I've always seen them as actual
characters not just monsters like they
have histories personalities I think
they're all extremely intelligent even
if they are just animals or just
monsters and so it was fun to sort of
come up with sequences that would allow
them to use all their abilities and
placed in environments that reflected
who they were so like with Mothra for
example to me she's this ancient goddess
you know she's the true protector of of
nature she's a benevolent protector so
placing her in sort of a jungle rain for
a setting in the ruins of an ancient
temple you know it just starts to
snowball with Rodan
you know he's always had these
interesting connections to volcanoes in
the original film the the Rodin couple
because there were two of them perished
in a volcano that they were nesting in
so it made sense to sort of go well what
if this version of Rodin is hibernating
within a volcano you know and then it
would emerge from that and then it just
gets the ball rolling I'm so curious
based on some of the things you've said
about the scheduling now when exactly
did the whole previz need to get the
green light thing happen compared to the
release dates for let's say Godzilla and
Kong Skull Island because I'm curious to
know what you were working with at that
point and that went and when those
movies came out what notes you were
given after the fact
well my process started like they first
approached me would have been March 2016
just finished Krampus was taking a break
and had dinner with Alex Garcia the
executive at legendary and
that's when he said that Gareth wasn't
returning because he was still busy with
Star Wars and I mean I think I said yes
before he got to finish asking the
question or I just assumed he would ask
the question you know as like a proposal
yes and so it started immediately so
March through spring and summer was
visual development combined with story
development and then while we were doing
that I think Skull Island came out was
2017 I think he was 17 so yeah like so
skål Island was kind of happening in the
background
you know while we were in development
and was you know nervous time because
its success or failure was ultimately
going to ripple out and affect us as
well thankfully it did very very well
for itself and was a really great movie
and so I think that gave the studio even
more faith in this particular film and
yeah it was it was also inspiring it was
inspiring to watch Jordan cross that
finish line with such a great fun
monster movie and know that we were sort
of waiting in the wings but also forced
us to step up a little bit yeah because
he definitely increased the intensity of
the monster fights and really raised the
bar in terms of the effects so it's like
we sort of scrambled back and re-examine
all our materials to make sure that we
were living up to that we're in a time
where social media and fandom is louder
than ever so one of the reactions that I
remember quite vividly from the 2014
Godzilla movie were some complaints that
we didn't get enough for the monster and
then I look at your trailer so I do
wonder or do you take that into account
that specific thing into account and
also from as like a director just in
general like what do you make of this
super loud voice that some studios and
filmmakers out there seemed to be taking
to heart and adjusting their movies yeah
what a minefield the thing is like I
really loved the approach that Gareth
took because I thought it was
brave I think if you're a true genre fan
you have an appreciation of slow-burn
genre films so that would include Blade
Runner Rosemary's Baby
jaws alien The Exorcist the thing like
those movies are slow burns and they're
alright and they're and the thing is or
also a lot Close Encounters of the Third
Kind of that list right so there was
definitely an era of slow burns on
refills and sadly that particular style
is a dying art form you know we don't
really get slow burn genre films that
much anymore and when we do they're
usually independent and they have very
catered audience but we don't get the
big slow burn movie so I thought it was
really smart and brave for Gareth and
legendary to take that approach because
it was a gamble and there's there's it's
a very particular skill to be able to
pull that off and I liked that I liked
being teased I liked that he felt sort
of mysterious and hidden and distant and
was revealed slowly over the course of
the film that said I also get what the
audience is saying I get what the masses
are screaming for I just wish culturally
that we had the nuance to shift gears
and acept the slow burn movie anymore
maybe I'm just too optimistic about
humanity to think that we could do that
but apparently we can anymore but we
just need constant action action action
regardless even if there wasn't a very
vocal contingent of the audience that
didn't that wasn't screaming for more
Godzilla I probably still would have
made the choices I did I probably still
would have made it more intense brought
in more monster action because I think
you get one shot of the slow burn the
own a mean like there was one slow Star
Trek movie and they did Racicot then you
know there was one slow alien film and
then it was aliens onward so even if
everyone did accept the lack of Godzilla
and the more nuanced approach that
Gareth did I think we still would have
evolved the tone and still taken off the
gloves he kind of took us a little bit
through the the pre process and how the
notes were coming in for you but I'm
curious about production and filming and
the the balancing act between getting
your your actor scenes your monster
scenes and working with the actors
playing the monsters the timeline on
that and what that particularly the
monster portion what it was like for you
to direct Godzilla well thankfully we
had a very generous schedule you know so
we really had the time we needed to to
make the film that we wanted to it was
like a good year of development slash
pre-production and then you had a 72
days shooting schedule and then over a
year at post-production so it wasn't
rushed by any means and that really
allowed me to focus on exactly what I
needed to focus in that one moment you
know of course as a director there's
always a million plates to spend you
feel like you never have enough time
you're pulled a million different
directions but like you know I had the
time to properly plan out the action
sequences the monster sequences using
you know as old-school traditional
methods like storyboards naturally but
had the time to really finesse edit and
shape the action sequences and freitas
which is one of my favorite parts of the
process because no one's telling you oh
that's too expensive you're not kind of
time to shoot that and because my crew
and I had that time we then got to plan
the shooting properly because that's
what previous is really great for it's
it can help you break down exactly what
portions of the set you need to build
what your camera angles are I mean my DP
I think got tired of me saying just
shoot like the previz because we really
spend a lot of time like you know the
the most subtle push in you know the you
know what moments - swish - handheld
etcetera it was I come from an animation
background I started off as an
old-school hand-drawn animator so I'm
used to really planning the [ __ ] out of
everything and then just executing
shot-for-shot you know and then bring it
all back together in the editing room
and so it was just very
as time and resources very careful
planning but it was really fun shooting
because even though we didn't have
obviously we didn't have a man in suit
on set with us I did everything I could
to make it feel like we did I did
everything could make it feel like the
monsters were there with us and so
whether it was the smoke the fire the
wind the rain anything that sort of
signified the how they changed the
environment
that the performers were in but I would
also play the roars of the monsters and
that was my favorite touch and that was
very much inspired by what freakin did
on The Exorcist because he had a
reputation for walking around and
shooting off a gun with blanks in it
till I get a proper jolt you know or
just to keep everybody a little bit
nervous and on edge and so I figured
what's the sort of Godzilla version of
that so I had the sound guys rig up
these giant speakers and then connect
that to an iPad that I had behind the
camera with me and so that had all the
roars of Godzilla Mothra Rodin etc and
so whenever monster we were shooting
within his given scene I would play the
different vocalizations and it it
sharpened the actors performances
because I think that there's some sort
of ancestral primal DNA from we were
monkeys like running from saber-toothed
Tigers on the savanna you don't I mean
you hear something roar and it just
triggers some instinct into you to get
the [ __ ] out of there and so with the
actors you saw their eyes go a little
bit bigger you know the breeding became
a little bit more shallow and rapid it
was a lot of fun who was the most
difficult to scare probably Kyle
Chandler you know he's such a dude you
know like he's just on a flappable this
movie or any of the other ones you've
made what's the craziest thing you've
done to get a natural scare in a scene
like that oh good question I mean I
don't know I have a habit of sneaking up
behind the camera to get a better really
good jump scare out of the actors you
know like just anything I can do to
trigger an actual shriek so with a on
trick or treat there's a moment when
Anna Paquin turns around when she's
walking through the woods
and sees dylan baker's character and so
her scare is very real you know cuz she
I purposely hid behind the camera and
jumped out of her and screeched out her
to get that actual rich reaction well
yeah I did the the junket for this film
Godzilla it not to not trick-or-treat
obviously all the actors mentioned the
sound effects oh where I would do is I
would start every day with Godzilla's
roar you mean so when we were sure it
was just like boom classic long roar
like let's get down to business I've
often heard other directors saying yeah
I play this kind of music to really set
them oh yeah Millie and Vera were very
big on using music to sort of help with
the emotional angle and it helped me to
really anything you can do to make the
the shooting of a scene feel like the
actual film or feel like a play you know
when it comes to godzilla himself and
sort of your approach to that iconic
figure i mean you know as you said you
don't have a man on suit on set and they
really wanted to capture that men on
suit vibe on the last godzilla and
interviews they said in interviews but
i'm curious like what was your read on
the character what was your approach to
his movement his personality his what he
stands for and is well i mean i think i
think Gareth did such a great job at
laying the groundwork yeah because I
from the design of Godzilla in that film
to the way he moved to the the way he
depicted the scale it was beautiful you
know it felt like I keep saying it's it
sort of felt like the Godzilla movie you
would see if he looked out your window
you know when I was a kid if I was ever
bored whether it was at school in church
what have you my go-to was to imagine
Godzilla showing up right so like
sitting in church just bored out of your
mind I would just fantasize about
Godzilla coming in just ripping off the
roof just to liven things
you're making me feel so much better
about my own yeah we're out there and so
that's what Gareth mean we felt like you
know like and he felt like a real animal
he felt like something that
paleontologist would discover and and
and say like this creature existed and
so I feel like I was just carrying that
forward I felt like you know the
marching orders were to embrace the
style that Gareth had set down I just
wanted to get to know guts a little more
you know there I've had a list of things
that I've always wanted to see in a
Godzilla movie but never had the chance
to and so I just sort of grabbed that
opportunity to construct scenes where
instead of him being so mysterious and
cryptic that we would get up close and
personal with him to really feel
normally feel like emotions you might
reserve for something like Hong Kong is
usually the kaiju that like gets the
more human bonding kind of moments
because he's a primate like us naturally
but I've always felt that towards
Godzilla right so it was more about
trying to construct a story that would
allow us those opportunities
I very much loved the obvious affection
that this movie has for Godzilla and
Mothra it was right in my what's not to
love about them yeah it seems like you
had some real creative freedom on this
big-budget studio movie which is kind of
a pleasant surprise to hear yeah was
that really the case and if you had a
fight for anything the most what was it
no that's the thing as you know people
come out of the process sometimes shaken
and gray and it's not to say that it
wasn't challenging that there weren't
difficulties but all the creative
partners involved from Warner Brothers
legendary Toho were insanely supportive
and it's a collaboration so of course
we're gonna have the opinions you're not
always going to agree I don't always
agree with myself sometimes you know
suddenly like there's an idea that I had
that was like super passionate about and
then a week later you're like what the
hell was I thinking
so of course there were notes and of
course sometimes there enraging but I
find what
learned over the years is sometimes you
just got to put your own ego aside and
just try it just see what happens and a
lot of times like it might not work but
a better idea still might come out of
the process it's like some super zen
studio director I have embraced the Zen
trust me like like when you walk through
the fire you have to come up with every
possible tool to get through it and you
know I've had so many great editors and
collaborators and mentors in the
industry that has sort of helped me see
the bigger picture and I got some really
great advice about listen it's like you
got to treat the studio like you would a
writing partner you know and I and
that's that advice really helped me kind
of shift how I view the process you know
it's easy just to sort of label all
studio notes as crap but I just know
from personal experience that's not the
case you know everybody wants to make a
good movie
having come out on the other side of
those notes and that experience sort of
jumping back to what I asked you what
would be your best advice for Godzilla
movie making oh I mean yeah I mean I'm
trying to think back to like what I told
Adam you know it was really the the main
thing or what I would tell myself you
know three years ago is is is pace
yourself you know it is a marathon it is
like climbing a mountain you know and
when you climb that mountain you can't
focus on the peak otherwise it's always
gonna seem impossible you just gotta
focus on like the next five steps ahead
of you and I definitely learned all
about that I learned about how much you
can really trust your collaborators and
as much as directing is about
maintaining your vision and keep trying
to keep control a lot of times it's also
about letting go like letting go the
control taking your hand off the wheel
and seeing what happens experimenting
being flexible enough because a lot of
times like again like fun things come
out of the spontaneous path you might
take better ideas might come out of it
and if it is going in the wrong
direction you can always hit on do you
know that's the beauty of sort of where
the technology has taken us is that you
can always experiment down a certain
path and if it sucks you can just go
back to the version we had and believe
me that happened too many times
is there any non-spoiler example of a
day where just like everything went to
[ __ ] but magical end up coming from it I
mean it's almost so many that it's just
overwhelming to even process honestly
it's like every day has it was a case of
you know what fresh hell is this
I warned Hayley I was gonna try to work
this into this episode and this question
is going to make absolutely no sense as
far as the transition goes but now that
you've had experience being part of a
cinematic universe where you're growing
a franchise and you're technically
making a sequel to something does this
give you any extra ammunition for making
a trick or treating for that trick or
treat to over like the last 10 years I
know I know and I and I feel terrible
because it sounds like my question where
my answer is always evasive and vague
but the truth is it's up to legendary
you know we had a sort of temporary
announcement back in I think it was 13
or 14 because I couldn't be there cuz I
didn't live here at the time but
somebody from legendary was kind enough
to send the poster to me it's free yeah
that's a really good post it was
beautiful thing but the thing is there's
been a regime change since then yeah I
would love to Sam's always gonna be my
baby I'm never gonna have kids so we're
just gonna be Sam and my dogs there's
nothing wrong with no not at all yeah
exactly
and I would love to it's just it's up to
legendary at this point and ultimately
how successful this film is but
creatively like I'm in like I if my
whole life is spent making monster
movies or all have a Halloween Christmas
and Godzilla I'm good I can Cove to the
grave on that
hich for you if I'm not gonna get
trick-or-treat to anytime soon or until
the legendary people say go you should
make a movie set in Iceland about
guerrilla I you know what I thought
about that and she actually showed up on
Sabrina yes she did and her own feature
though very very possible I love you
know turning to folklore mythology for
movie monsters so anything's possible
but yeah we'll see we'll see I I you
thought it could be fun to do like a
trick-or-treat Halloween special you
know I mean like in the tradition of old
Halloween specials but I feel like even
that won't appease the fans who want
nothing but a true sequel I have to
imagine at this point if they do get
their heads right and give it the green
light you gotta be pretty ready to go on
it right I mean I have the concepts for
sort of the stories yeah and we're
wooden could go and even ideas for
casting and whatnot but again is it's
it's it's sort of above my paygrade
yeah are you comfortable saying if Sam
is hidden anywhere in Godzilla
well he's not oh yeah I felt too
self-serving here's my pitch crossover
crossover yeah you can have a kid run
also I just really want to see a
Godzilla movie at Halloween now see that
I'd want to see any movie set during
that specific day as we kind of wind
down here one thing we always like to
ask our guests is if there's anything
happening in genre right now whether
it's movies TV books you name it that
really excites you a specific property a
trend anything at all I mean the the
cool thing about that question is that
we can even ask that question right now
because it is a golden age as far as
horror sci-fi and fantasy is concerned I
won't presume to know how old you guys
are but I remember the dark times when
your choices for genre television where
x-files our Buffy and that was kind of
it you know and it was like
horror comedy anthology off the ground
next to impossible and there was a point
when you couldn't even pitch an
anthology show your agents wouldn't even
allow you to pitch an anthology show
because it was like considered the a
word you know like there wasn't a single
network that would even consider it and
now it's like they're popping up left
and right
so the cool thing is that you can ask
like what's your favorite sci-fi fantasy
or superhero show and there's a wealth
of possible options right now in TV I'm
watching Sabrina
Cobra Kai and what we do in the shadows
is a great story and that's all I have
room for right now I know the list is
going to get longer
you know we've now put Game of Thrones
behind us I'm looking forward to like
watch men on some of the other stuff on
the horizon but like those are my 3
right now and and then you know in the
film space again there's just so much
you know there's the obvious choices
like you know all of the Marvel Universe
films obviously like very reliable but I
find that because I was working on a big
giant loud noisy tentpole movie I've
been gravitating towards the smaller
films sort of counterbalance that a
little bit so Suspiria was a favorite
and you just said the right timing a
gourmet meal you know and I can watch
Tilda Swinton
anything and annihilation was another
one in like the wish and so anything
anything that did embrace sort of the
slow burn quiet horror or quiet sci-fi
like that's been my go-to because it was
like putting on noise-canceling
headphones while I'm normally dealing
with 400 foot tall monsters as my danger
your t-shirt is distracting me Oscar how
you feeling about all the Stephen King
adaptations right now I'm in yeah I want
that one but again like like as someone
who grew up in first generation Stephen
King in the 80s when the books are first
getting published and read those books
you know for
ferociously to know that he's popular
nothing ever wasn't popular but you know
what I mean like there's hills and
valleys to every every trend mhm and
there definitely was a valley for
Stephen King fans for a while where they
weren't they just weren't getting made
the adaptations were happening so to see
that it's now on the rise again it's
reaching like this fever pitch I mean I
couldn't be happier it kind of changed
the game it didn't it did but it was
also surrounded by multiple Stephen King
adaptations that came out in the same
year it was like you know that shared
consciousness being very cool yeah you
could get your hands on any Stephen King
whether it's been made whether it's it
which just came out and obviously would
never happen but what's like what's the
one that touches your heart cycle of the
werewolf nice I really love cycle of the
werewolf like as a kid it was such a
different kind of book because it was an
illustrated graphic novel with Bernie
Wrightson doing the illustrations and so
it came along at a perfect point in the
mid 80s when yeah I loved the books but
to cease DST even King's Story
Illustrated for you in such a graphic
visual way and also just a very classic
Stephen King story it's sort of a
whodunit where the perpetrator is a
werewolf it just pushed all the right
buttons for me I'm adding it to my queue
right now never seen it I've I've been
on a Stephen King binge since it came
out you know I've been a genre lover all
my life and I've had people that have
encouraged me to read but I never really
got into reading for fun for a long long
time and ever since it came out I think
I've read like a dozen books for the
first time you know and I'm not stopping
anytime so you got to check out cycle
the werewolf it was also it was adapted
as a film called Silver Bullet yes yes
yes very different but by the way I
think it's underrated I really do it's
got some really fantastic moments
because it's it's spirit is inspiration
is still Stephen King yeah that cycle of
the werewolf is I think my first Stephen
King book I just grabbed it out of my
dad's bookshelf did not sleep that night
great perfect
Tai's and when you read that one you got
to get a hard copy though because you
have to see the art that goes I'm in an
audiobook craze right now all right
don't stop this is a this is all right
Saturday afternoon I see it right here I
can easily click purchase and make it
happen
I'm going to send you down this rabbit
yeah exactly I am happy to go down it at
this point any final questions before we
wrap this up I feel I should hand that
to you since I'm gonna do this second
function I I have so many questions but
you guys know I have yet to see your
movie I cannot wait to see it very very
soon when this episode goes up I will
probably be seeing it within 24 hours
Hayley has had the pleasure of seeing it
so the reason why you guys are getting a
shorter episode of the witching hour
right now is so we could save some time
to explore all the spoilers the ending
explains whatever you want to call it
for Godzilla and Hayley is gonna have
the pleasure of having that chat with
Mike I just promise me you'll see it on
the biggest screen you can yeah I'm
gonna see it on whatever screen that
Warner Brothers is reviving and then if
that's not big enough I will go and see
it that market as well alright alright
alright guys thank you so much for
watching this episode of the witching
hour
Hayley where can everyone find you on
the Internet you can find me on twitter
at haley foutch and you can find me on
instagram at haystack McGrew b and other
than the release of godzilla king of
monsters hitting theaters super soon now
where do you want to send all of our
viewers to check out your stuff to keep
following you well after the Sun comes
out I'm all I have is Twitter that's it
like I I can't dip I shut down my
Facebook account in 2010 and never
looked back and Instagram terrifies me
so yeah I'm just on Twitter what's your
handle oh it's Mike underscore Doherty
Instagram is fun you don't have to
participate but it is kind of fun just
to like follow things that you're
excited about our culture when someone's
entire feed is nothing but photos of
themselves like I'm watching
the body-snatchers in all right guys you
can catch me on twitter and instagram @
PM ralph again Godzilla king of the
monsters in theaters May 31st check it
out also hit all the comment sections
hit us up on Twitter as well we want to
know what you think of the movie when
you guys see it thank you so much for
watching and listening to this episode
you've officially survived the witching
hour